ready when you are
okay good morning everybody
welcome to this joint audit and
standards committee i am councillor dave
muller and i am chairing the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons
in the chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless when you are moving around the
building
once you have taken your seat you may
remove your mask please ensure that you
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting
and during any breaks please ensure that
microphones are turned off
when not in use that you do not
interrupt
other speakers that if you are attending
the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting
on the modern.gov app i would like to
remind everyone present that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also cons
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings
for webcasting and or for training
purposes
the council members the public and the
press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i know like to make some introductions
the officers attending the meeting today
are emily ewell
the monitoring officer good morning
emily catherine still
assistant director for corporate
resources good morning catherine
melissa evans corporate manager for
finance and commissioning and
procurement good morning melissa
and mandy smith the governance officer
good morning mandy
can i now move to the agenda please can
we have
item one apologies for absence of any
substitutions thank you amanda
thank you chair and we've received
apologies uh from councillor lindsay
and apologies from councillor castin
who has been substituted by councilman
ek peng young
and we have councillor nan amirosen
and war boys not in attendance thank you
very much
um item number two do we have any
declaration
declarations of interest from any
members present please
no thank you very much item three i'd
like to move on to the minutes
of the meeting jsac 21-1 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 17th
of may
2021 these are all in your papers on
pages 5 to 12
and we're actually looking for accuracy
etc on these
does anyone have any questions about the
accuracy or any other issues with the
minutes
councilman sharon please thank you thank
you chair
um on page 7 36.2
at our last meeting i asked or requested
some more information about the
performance and where those
areas were lacking in or below standard
of performance
and where there was scope for
improvement and i
don't remember i've had a response to
that
thank you very much thank you very much
so i've received that information this
morning councilman karen so i
forward that on to everybody after the
meeting
thank you mandy thank you very much
mandy thank you mayor
are there any other issues with the
minutes on
that meeting in which case can i have
a proposal and a second to please for
those minutes proposed by councillor
huron
seconded by councillor norris thank you
very much
if you'd like to go to the vote and
could i ask randy please to conduct
thank you chair if you'd like to go
through the modern.gov
app that vote is now in progress
councilman i'm going to take your vote
cool
thank you
thank you chair that's unanimous six
votes for thank you
do we have any place non-received chair
thank you very much
item five do we have any questions from
the public
run received thank you and item six do
we have any questions from councillors
thank you very much mandy therefore we
will move on to
item number seven um this is the
jac21 stroke two the treasury management
out term report for 20 20 21
and can i please ask melissa evans to
present the report please
thank you melissa thank you chair good
morning councillors
so this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position
for the out term for the financial year
2020-21
it provides details of performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management
policy the report explains in more
details the factors affecting the
strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions
interest rate and liquidity risk
the kovid pandemic dominated last year
and the impacts of the global lockdown
the start of the financial year saw many
central bank banks cutting interest
rates as lockdown caused
economic activity to grind to a halt
the uk government provided a range of
fiscal stimulus measures
the size of which has not been seen in
peace time
the vaccine approval and subsequent
rollout program are both positives for
the financial services sector in general
but there remains much uncertainty
around the level of losses the banks and
building societies will suffer due to
the
economic slowdown the bank of england
held the bank rate at 0.1
throughout the year but extended its
quantitative easing program by 150
billion
to 895 billion in november 2020.
the uk unemployment rate was 5 in the
three months to january 2021
and unemployment is still expected to
increase as various government job
support schemes come
to an end inflation has remained low
over the 12-month period
and the latest figures show the annual
headline rate of uk
consumer price inflation otherwise known
as cpi
fell to 0.4 year one year in february
well below expectations of 0.8 and
further below the bank of england's
target of 2
moving on to specifically for our two
councils
both councils were able to take
advantage of holding additional cash
from the government grant schemes
received during the year relating to
covid
until they were paid out to support
local businesses
this has obviously increased the
treasury activity during the year
regarding banking activities both
councils operated within daily bank
accounts limits
limits and each council has increased
its short-term debt
favor by 15.5 million and mid-suffolk by
19.6 million
each council lent a further 19.3 million
to cifco limited
and mid suffolk lent further 600 000 to
gateway 14 limited
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix c of the report
investments by both councils in funding
circle has reduced
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid
for baber this was 48 000 of the 214k
previously invested and for mid suffolk
it was 53 000
of the 215 000 invested leaving the
balances at the 31st of march of 166
000 for baber and 162 000 for mid
suffolk
both councils are compliant with the
upper limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity
undertaken for the year was done so in
priority order of security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
and finally i just want to draw members
attention to
an error in appendix c paragraph 1.4
table 4 and that's on page 24.
in the mid suffolk table there's two
figures
in the 31st of march 21 column
and the balances have been transposed so
the ccla balance should read
5 million not 2 million and the investec
balance should read 2 million not
5 million i confirm there's been no
changes in either of the amounts
invested in these funds
and the figures for baby in the table
are correct
finally i've got if anyone's got any
questions um catherine or myself are
here to
to answer them thank you
does any member have any questions for
melissa on the paper please
councilman thank you sure uh
4.7 melissa where there's
a difference between the the interest
rate
applied to the long-term borrowing of
different in both councils
what what is the different what is the
impact of that
that's page 15.
sorry can we just check the page number
it's just in our pack
no mine's not
[Applause]
15. it won't five
sorry sorry that was uh
my mistake one phone
4.7 is it in one of the particular
appendices because i think page
one five in this pack is the end of the
the report itself
is there an appendix sorry
oh is it not oh
no no it's in the main presentation
document
it's 4.7 be the same
now that is interesting isn't it
yeah i think actually might be a little
bit more helpful councilman karen if you
if you have a look on page
20 it might give you a little bit more
information
in a table format because we show the
long term and the short term borrowing
now the reason for the the long term
borrowing between babe remid suffolk the
3.19 and the 3.07 i assume those are the
same numbers in the table
that you're referring to it's that's the
pwlb
borrowing relating to the council
housing stock
so at the time when we borrowed they
were obviously different
different officers in charge of those
decisions at the time so
it's historical yeah okay thank you i i
haven't matched up the page but never
mind i'll look at that afterwards
thank you and i've just just one sort of
just comment
uh a lot of the impact has been about
the higher level of unemployment
as in part of your report
is that because at the moment we see a
mismatch between
a high level of unemployment but many
companies can't recruit
is that something that might impact us
so
that's about i can try and answer that
one cancer
i don't think it should impact our
treasury management
activity obviously it might have other
impacts on the on the two councils
but in terms of our treasury management
activity i don't think it will have a
direct impact
suggesting perhaps it had an impact on
the treasury management but it might
have an impact on
overall on the council itself
yes yes certainly and the people on the
council tax reduction scheme as well we
might see an increase in
in people claiming that as well
certainly universal credit claimants
have gone up a lot over the last 18
months and
with the furlough scheme ending that
could that could go up further again
um i was just wondering uh on
page 24 uh table four
um the movement in the ccla
amount has that ended up in the investec
fund or is that just a currency no that
was the the error that i mentioned
at in the intro that that should be
the same they both should be the same no
no funds have changed between ccla and
investex so
we will correct that for the council
version so they should be the same
okay so the the movement in the
investing i'm looking at mid suffolk now
uh where did the three million come from
it didn't there shouldn't have been a
three million movement in there
okay i'm still puzzled because
there's a movement from the prior year
to the year we're just considering of 3
million
so where did the 3 million come from if
i could perhaps uh help with that one
councillor
if you look at the ccla line above and
the invest tech line
below you'll see there's three million
on each of those two lines
and what melissa was explaining was that
was an error
that three million shift shouldn't be
there so ccla should still be five
million
at the end of 2021 and investex should
still be
2 million at the end of 2021
right got it
okay brilliant thank you very much
um and with regard to the money market
fund
um i'm not entirely clear from reading
the report that
um we may not have lost lost money on on
those funds
and like to understand the advice that
we was given in regard to that fund
and what the costs were for managing it
yeah we do obviously pay broker fees for
any investments we make in the money
market funds and obviously the rate
that we're getting you can see at the
end the average rate is 0.01
for investing into that's the money
coming back to us so we haven't actually
lost money but the returns we're getting
are lower than what we would have been
experiencing the previous year for
example so that would be the only
negative impact so would
a curious point then would we have paid
more in fees than we got
in returns no um we did there was a
chance at one point where we would be
actually paying money to
invest in but they have waivered that
for and they still are at the moment so
they're not charging us to to do that so
that's still still the case
okay thank you
um just a clarification really it
doesn't particularly affect this
document um
it might do when we were on ons the
other day we had uh the net figure
of the cifco return to the council
because i think it actually is 0.3
um but when we were discussing it
we we said it was three point but i
think actually the total net
to the council is actually 0.3 isn't it
i think if you have a look at the table
on page 29. i couldn't see it in here
um and i just wanted because we had a
bit of discussion about it the other day
at ons
and i queried it in the minutes
um and i really just want clarification
whether i'm wrong or
we've got it wrong in the minutes but um
it i know it's definitely more than .3
percent it did actually say 0.3 on the
table when we had it
at the right at the bottom so when
everything was netted down
after all costs after everything the net
benefit to
the council didn't seem to come in at
0.3 which is why i queried it because it
seemed very low
whether that was in the wrong place on
the table and it is actually three
percent if it is three percent which is
what you answered
yes yes i think that's i'm happy with
that because that's correct but it did i
think initially it said on there it was
0.3
which looks particularly bad which is
why i queried it yeah
well check the report because obviously
this if copies yeah they take you so
much reporting because that will be
going
i'm not hoping that it was wrong with my
and i'm wrong and it is actually um
three yeah it's it's somewhere somewhere
i think it's somewhere between two and
three percent but i'll check that out
right okay that's fine just just a query
on that really
do we have any more questions for
members please
no then i'd like to open up the debate
do you mem members like to debate this
particular paper
um i don't need much to debate really as
it's only for noting um i'd like to
propose that we note it and vote
accordingly as
anyone's got any burning questions and
about debating it
um as we've already had questions i'm
not quite sure
where we debate we don't actually have
to vote on this particular item purely
because it is
for noting so so basically i'll go
through the recommendation
recommendation 3.1
is that the treasury management activity
for the year 20
20 21 be noted and it be noted that
performance was in line with the
prudential
indicator set for 2021 recommendation
3.2 is that it be noted that both
councils treasury management activity
420 2021 was in accordance with the
approved treasury management strategy
and that the councils have complied with
all the treasury management indicators
for this period
so thank you for that we now move on to
item number eight
which is the jac 21 3 complaints
and i would like to ask emily ewell if
she could present her report please
thank you emily
check if i can just ask you to go back
to the previous item
um i think you might need to actually
make a recommendation there to
to recommend you might need to vote
because it's a recommendation to the
councils
so the committee needs to confirm that
it is recommending these two
to the councils to approve okay
apologies for that
um i'm sorry counselor uh
chair i guess that when we vote on that
that's in
in taking into account the corrections
that have been made yes
yes yes
yes apologies chair i'm now setting that
up um so i'm
just going to put you agree to the
recommendations within the report
thank you councillors if you'd like to
go to the modern.gov
that vote is now in progress
councillor bingham four thank you
thank you chair that's unanimous six
votes for thank you very much
thank you chair good morning everyone
i'm pleased to introduce the code of
conduct complaints monitoring report for
the period
19th of march to the 12th of july 2021
although there is a slight reduction in
the number of complaints compared
with the previous reporting period the
time period is shorter for the current
report so the level of complaints
has received and received has remained
consistently high
the complaints in the baby district are
higher but tend to be multiple
complaints
linked to a small number of specific
issues
we continue to receive a large number of
informal queries and requests for advice
from town and parish councils
about matters such as casual vacancies
meeting procedures
and declarations of interests the
complaints monitoring information is for
noting only
however i'm also requesting that the
committee resolves to receive an annual
complaints
monitoring report in the future the
current frequency of reporting
often means that the committee does not
receive a full picture
of the whole history of each complaint
due to the lifespan of the complaint
overlapping reporting periods moving to
an annual report would help to present a
more accurate picture
and to enable better comparison between
the reporting periods
committee members are also invited to
suggest any additional information
they would like to see in the report
chair i'm very happy to take any
questions but i will not be able to
discuss
the details of any individual complaints
thank you
members do we have any questions for
emily please
thank you thank you emily um
i think um i've got
more than two questions i don't want to
sort of go before other members of the
committee
um i think the first question i was
going to ask emily
was about the mark difference between
weber district council and mid-suffolk
council and was really thinking about
was it
based on one subject or one
incident or one issue but i think you've
answered that because you said it
there were a group of complaints so
that's answered my first question
from a practical point of view how soon
um are counsellors advise that there is
a complaint against them
thank you for the question um so
normally
the counselor is um advised of the
complaint after the
initial assessment which can take up to
four weeks
um and during that initial assessment
what we do is we
check that the code is engaged so is it
actually a code of conduct complaint and
not a service complaint or a
complaint about a procedure for example
and we also
assess other criteria such as is it a
vexatious complaint
is it a repeated complaint or does it
relate to a counsellor that's no longer
in office for example so that's the kind
of initial assessment
and at that stage if we have deemed it a
valid code of conduct complaint the
councillor who's been accused of the
misdemeanor will be then informed unless
there is a good reason not to inform the
councillor at that stage
for example if it's a uh potentially a
criminal matter
something of that of that nature and we
need to obviously preserve the the
investigation
thank you
thank you um looking at the four
complaints for babel district council
i'm not sure where you you can disclose
this
but were they public
complaints or within the council itself
the complaints made by either other
or the general public
so the complaints around declarations of
interest
were made by members of the public and
the complaints about um
the uh failing to treat others with
respect
were from councillors towards
councillors
however whoever makes the complaint has
no bearing on
how we process the complaint all
complainants are treated equally
so back to the i picked up the
treat others with respect
the question i would ask is
what happens if a counselor despite
being advised
to discontinue that behavior what
happens if they continue
to offend
thank you that's a really good question
and it's also one of the
kind of more frustrating limitations of
the code of conduct as it stands at the
moment because
of course my recommendations are that
recommendations they they are not
enforceable sanctions
um however if we do make formal
recommendations following a code of
conduct complaint
after a council has been found in breach
of the code and they fail to comply with
those recommendations
we can convene a meeting of the
standards committee
um and the council is brought forward to
that committee and asked
to explain why they failed to um
to fulfill those recommendations and the
committee can
make further or impose further sanctions
for example public censure thank you
i'll keep going
when you advise somebody to make an
apology
what assurance do we have that
that actually happens
so for a complaint about a district
councillor it would be my responsibility
to ensure that that apology is is
delivered either
in a public apology in a meeting for
example or a formal written apology
depending on the nature of the incident
for town and parish councils it usually
falls to the clerk to ensure that that
apology has been undertaken um
but more often than not if the apology
is not given we hear back from the
person who's made the complaint
to report back to us that that hasn't
hasn't happened and then we would take
further steps as i've described
and potentially convening the standards
committee if required
thank you that just emphasizes the
importance of the role of the parish
clerk actually in relation to parish
councillors doesn't it
and and sort of the training and support
parish clerks get
in relation to this sort of incident
um in return in relation to the
non-declaration of interest do you apply
that to parish councils or is it just
for the district council
i know in the minutes of a parish
council meeting there will be
but if somebody actually has complained
that there hasn't been a non
declaration of interest uh what
sort of what would happen after that if
it was a parish council
thank you yeah
so the requirement to declare interests
applies to all tiers of local government
so it applies to town of parishes
equally as to the district council
so there's two routes really if it's a
non-declaration of a local non-pecunory
interest
there's not really a great deal of
impact because that person was still
entitled to
participate in the meeting and to vote
so
in that case we tend to just offer words
of advice and
suggest that the parish council might
want to take up some training either
from ourselves or from
the suffolk association of local
councils if it's a failure to declare a
pecuniary
interest potentially there is a criminal
offence
so we would need to consider whether the
incident would need to be reported to
the police
and also we would work with the parish
clerk
to identify whether that person
participating in the meeting having not
declared that pecuniary interest
had any material impact on the outcome
of the vote that was taken by the parish
council
and we would suggest that the parish
clerk as the proper officer of the
council
uh assesses that and and decides whether
they need to take any action
in terms of revisiting that decision
because of the potential impact of
somebody who shouldn't have been allowed
to participate in in that particular
item
thank you emily thank you for the report
thank you chair
counselor please thank you
thank you mr chairman um i'm looking at
page 47 4.4 and 4.5
you've made a recommendation to go to an
annual reporting cycle which
seems fine um i just wondered whether
you had some idea of how this reports
what it's going to look like and what
its contents are going to be
and whether you had considered looking
at the trend of the different types of
complaints that
are received year upon year
thank you for for the question and chair
it's it's absolutely my intention
that an annual report would be able to
give a much
richer set of information to the
committee so we could do
a lot more analysis about the trends the
types of complaints
we could report if the committee so
wished on
um where the complaints have come from
so is it a member of the public is it a
member of staff is it a
a fellow counsellor so we could present
that kind of analysis
as well um and i think what it would
give us is a much um clearer
indication of the kind of life cycle of
each complaint because sometimes the
outcome of the complaint is missed
in the data that we present to you
because in the first period it hasn't
been concluded yet and in the next
period it's not included in the data
because it's been closed
so it would give that much clearer sense
i also think it would be able to we
would be able to look at any kind of
seasonal nature
of the complaints so for example
around an election time you may get more
complaints because people are
complaining about the campaign
so things like that and i think it would
give
the committee um that kind of richer
sense rather than just a set of
figures
thank you for that i just wondered also
if you might consider looking at
how long it's taken to actually resolve
or any of these complaints
thank you
oh thank you um uh however i think my
question has just been answered from
what
has been said thank you
thank you
i've got to do this i apologize if i've
missed this point but um am i to
understand correctly
that
apologies for misconduct are
not mandatorily public
they can be a private email at the time
but they will eventually come out in the
reports so
is that right yeah you're absolutely
right councillor
an apology as a recommended sanction
doesn't have to be a public apology it
could be a private apology
and sometimes that would be absolutely
the right thing to do
depending on the nature of the complaint
if it's a very sensitive complaint for
example
the complaints aren't routinely made
public
and particularly the witness statements
of the complainant and the council are
providing
their their evidence because obviously
we need to protect
the personal data rights of all involved
but if a complaint does go to the
standards committee that of course is
public
because of the um the report that goes
alongside
the the committee's consideration and
also any decision notices that we issue
are our public as well and would be
releasable
are are complaints that are withheld
from the public
subject to freedom freedom of
information requests
yes part of the some parts of the
complaints
information would be releasable under
the freedom of information act
thanks thank you do we have any more
questions at all councillor haran please
yes i am on i wonder um if you could
just be a bit more specific
um 10 complaints against baby
councillors that could be um
ten against one or one against ten are
you able to put a number on that
just just to give us a feeling um
is it just one little outbreak or is it
more
widely spread please
so um here again chair there is a
division between the
complaints received against um parish
councillors and complaints received
against district councillors
and the complaints against district
councillors tend to be
quite individualized so they are six
separate
complaints against six separate
councillors whereas the town and parish
complaints
tend to be multiple complaints around
the same issue
and that could be that um
for example we had one complaint by a
single complainant
against eight councillors and they were
all submitted individually so there were
eight complaints
effectively about the same issue and
then there's also complaints that might
be made
by multiple people against the one
councillor for the
for the same issue if if that makes
sense chair
question but maybe you're not able to
which is um
fair enough i just wondered a more
specific number of district councillors
who were being
complained against if you can't give me
that it'd be nice to know if it's two
three or five or
ten singles just to give us an idea of
how widespread it is i would make the
other point
um you seem to be asking to move to an
annual
report and i'm just wondering is now the
right time to do it we do seem to have a
maybe a slight bubble of um discontent i
think we should have an annual report i
also think we should um
keep an eye on this at every meeting
that's my personal feeling because
we need to be ahead of the game i think
it just seems an annual report is
maybe not paying enough attention but
i'm mindful of what other counsellors
may think but that is um my point of
view thank you chair
very much do we have any more questions
at all
not at all we can now go into debate do
you members wish to debate this topic
further
thank you no okay
and then council mclaren uh thank you
chair i mean
in the light of the comment from
councillor haran i guess um
i wondered if we needed to modify the
recommendation
that was being put before us in terms of
the the need to review the information
at every meeting
is a bit of a question rather than the
paper i don't i don't have any points of
debate i've already made my points
i do i just wanted to support what
counselor harum was saying
about this coming on a regular basis to
this committee
because i you know looking at the
for babera district council anyway i
think it's something that we should be
looking at
in more depth if that's possible with
this committee or whether it has to go
to another committee
um casey barra please yeah i don't think
we should get too high
upon the numbers because clearly um if
you look at it i mean
from a perspective it looks pretty bad
as if we're a dysfunctional council
but actually what it could mean is we
were an active council and we're
actually pursuing policies that
obviously there are some people who
don't like and actually when you look at
the majority of those are actually
parish council so nothing to do with us
really
and i would probably surmise that the
ten that we get
having had some pretty uh
um and difficult planning decisions
recently
i would suggest and i don't know because
also i'm not
privy to that information they're
probably around that sort of area where
you tend to get that where people get
very angry about
things and then wang out a letter or
complaint
but really hasn't got any basis and that
does tend to be this
if you look at the upheld complaints
it's very minimal and i don't know how
many of the baby ones are upheld
so which is maybe what we could
differentiate
so we can see which baby ones are upheld
which parish ones are upheld
because obviously that just having seven
doesn't give us a clear indication of
where there was fault so maybe that
could be a recommendation
um that we have that we could see
what percentage was upheld against each
particular council
sector
um emily would it be possible bearing in
mind what councillor huron and cash
mclaren said that we could still perhaps
have our
regular report but you did mention when
you were speaking earlier that
that the end-of-year report will be a
much more detailed report which i would
certainly welcome and i'm sure
colleagues would certainly welcome that
as well
and perhaps the recommendation could be
amended that we continue to receive
your regular report in addition to a
more substantial annual report
would you be happy with that would
members be happy with that
thank you yeah yes chair
more than happy um to continue with this
kind of statistical report
on a on a quarterly basis and then look
for that more
analytical and rich annual report um to
provide that
that kind of um trend data if you like
i must admit i would particularly like
to see a more substantial annual report
i think it would be quite interesting
and i know members would
obviously find that interesting well as
well but i do think it's important
we are kept up to date with with the
individual report as
as and when we we have done so far so if
we could kindly sort of
thank you emily if we could perhaps
amend that um
uh amendment that we will continue with
the um
regular report in addition to an annual
report and
if members are happy with that could i
have a proposal and a second to please
count strep and young and counselor
bound yeah thank you very much thank you
and we'll let um the governance officer
type that in
and then we'll go to the electronic vote
thank you
i just read the the actual
recommendation for 3.1 is that the code
of contact complaints monitoring
information
containing paper jac 2016 be noted
and the recommendation 3.2 that the code
of conduct complaints monitoring
report to be reported joint order and
standards committee on an annual basis
we need to vote on that but also we will
continue with the
the regular reports that we get thank
you
thank you chair so excuse me i've
amended that by
um just to say to approve the
recommendation 3.2 as detailed in the
report
um amended as agreed thank you very much
our members happy with that
pose and the second day thank you thank
you very much yes
thank you mandy so that vote is now in
progress
council right now thank you
thank you
okay karen joe can i just raise this
this is just an addendum really about
parish
i'm concerned about parish councils
perhaps because
one or two incidents that happened
within my own ward
and it's the about the support
and the training or lack of it
and i raised it in another meeting
actually and john
said she would pursue my concern which
was personal to me
but i i in terms of parish councillors
and
and the work of parish councils i'm just
a bit concerned they're not getting the
support that they need
thank you thank you chair
make your vote councillor norris
councillor norris are you are you maybe
able to vote on an
at or would you like to give your vote
verbally
would you like to give your vote
verbally i haven't received your vote on
the app
thank you uh that is unanimous chair
seven votes for
which is jac 21-4 and um
this is the actual forward plan are
there any suggestions
comments or amendments to the forward
plan for members please
no okay therefore the audit and
standards plans for baby suffolk are
noted
and this actually concludes the meeting
the next meeting is currently scheduled
for the 27th of september 2021
commencing at 9
30 and i hereby declare the meeting
closed at 10
19 up 10 19.
thank you casey barrack thank you thank
you everybody thank you emily thank you
you